[Music]
let's talk about episodes I have to tell
you I went and talked to you before but
before we we started the show tonight
I'm a huge fan of episodes and really
loved the show you're hilarious on the
show it's a great idea and a lot of fun
yeah it's the same David Crane and
Jeffrey klarik and David created friends
so it's the someone I really trust
writing it and it's been a lot of fun we
shoot in London and you know it's on
Showtime so there's kind of a they give
us a lot longer leash then you can get
on the network right somebody'd swear
and show naked people it's very funny
don't make it stuffs fantastic and you
look amazing but but you know I would
say it's such a funny idea it's it's
about these British British writers or
producers that create a show in England
it's very dignified and it's like a kind
of a PBS show and then an American
brings it here and then makes them cast
you reallyyou matt LeBlanc is the lead
and then they change the show a lot and
it's this culture clash but it really
works
yeah like the show was about the hat in
London there's their original show was
about a headmaster of a boys Academy who
was hopelessly in love with the
librarian who was a lesbian and when
they get to America itself
it turns into my show about me as the
hockey coach really dumb it down yeah
now here's the I heard this and I didn't
believe it that you shoot it takes place
in in Hollywood in Los Angeles and and
and in this area in show business
you shoot it entirely in London which I
couldn't believe because that's a you
know the you you don't notice when you
watch the show but what's it like
shooting in London for Los Angeles
difficult yeah London doesn't really
look too much like yeah I wouldn't think
so yeah I think it's just budget
constraints so that's why we shoot it
there and it's been interesting do you
like London do you or do you like
hanging out there yes that's a cool town
yeah I like it I mean I like it it's
good for me because that's the climate
I'm supposed to be living in
all my people are from like a foggy
boggy area and I'm supposed to walk
around in the rain and every now and
then see a little Sun over the hill but
mostly just eat like mud cakes and hide
in the house but I don't know that you
would like that I mean well we shot the
first season we were there like spring
into the summer and that was great
second season we were there in the
winter not so great but this London's
funny in the summer time because the
weather is so foul so often when the Sun
does come out
you see these pasty English people just
peeling their clothes off if there was
this much grass would be ten guys
fighting to lay down on little parks
everywhere this just looks like you know
just mass sunbathing and bright you just
you just described a picnic in my
neighborhood so knock it off we have a
clip here from episodes this is a scene
I think where your your producers is the
the British couple that from England
they've called you in Matt LeBlanc to
talk about your weight I guess that's
from episodes
they're all going on about he's gained
so much weight he's such a chunk and I'm
like I'm sorry I just don't see it
so he says everyone's going on about
does that include you I was not the one
who said chunk I may have said you
gained a little which I haven't
obviously I stand corrected but you
think I look like I have I think you're
an enormous ly attractive manager and
I'm just hearing the word enormous I
think you look great hello who's the
only one in this room who slept with you
[Applause]